ja dann habe ich jetzt wirklich zwei
leute die halt wirklich aktiv mit ihnen
geschrieben haben dazu bekommen dass sie
mir screenshot senden von dem ganzen
chat verlauf und da war ich dann
wirklich zum teil schon so etwas klappt
jetzt willkommen beim neuen video und
zwar habe ich heute wirklich eine
richtig krass soll ich für euch also die
schon relativ krass ich bin immer noch
ziemlich krank mir jetzt schon besser
aber ich bin noch krank und meinem
scheiß zimmer ist es wirklich so fucking
warm aber ich muss dieses video jetzt
einfach für euch abdrehen weil es mich
so unnormal aufregt wie man so gestört
sein kann und zwar kurz luft holen ich
hab ja unter anderem auch eine
facebook-seite das wissen die wenigsten
von euch das habe ich auch noch nie
gesagt wie hat glaube ich so acht oder
neun 1000 likes ist einfach mal in der
video beschreiben und verlinkt deswegen
hier könnte mal gerne drauf league und
leichter lassen würde mich sehr freuen
auf jeden fall habe ich ja diese seite
und auf dieser seite habe ich wirklich
vorgestern glaube ich wirklich acht oder
neuen nachrichten bekommen von
irgendwelchen leuten wo drinsteht
bist du wirklich der von dbna punkt com
oder de bug.de keine ahnung und ich
dachte mir so hey wenn ich das wirklich
so häuft ist wahrscheinlich wieder
irgendeinen fake account von mir
unterwegs so ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
wenn man so videos macht ich es ist zwar
schade aber es gehört halt dazu das ist
auch wirklich so viele fake-accounts
beziehungsweise accounts gibt auch
kinder keine ahnung wo bei diesem dbna
halt auch da komme ich jetzt gleich zu
oder facebook mein ding auch keine
ahnung die hat einfach deine fotos
benutzt muss vermieters luft tut man ich
will nicht mehr krank sein so wie gesagt
leute deine fotos benutzen ist normal
die haben dann meistens einen anderen
namen und dann kam aber wirklich dieser
fake account bei diesem dbna wo ich
überhaupt nicht wusste was das ist das
maßlos komplett übertrieben hat und ich
frag mich junge was ist los mit dir
warum machst du das man ich verstehe
einfach nicht was in den köpfen von
solchen leuten vor gericht ich meine da
hat man muss sich doch richtig ich
könnte was nicht ich würde mich so
unnormal schäden auf jeden fall habe ich
dann mal geguckt das waren alles jungs
die mir geschrieben haben ist überhaupt
nicht schlimm es war halt einen schwulen
portal also
okay ich habe mir eigentlich angewöhnt
homosexuell zu sagen weil das wort
schwul habe ich auch in einigen videos
schon mal ein bisschen negativ benutzt
was eigentlich voll dumm ist weil gut
deswegen sage ich jetzt homosexuell auf
jeden fall
es ist ein homosexuelles forum für
jugendliche oder auch männer
woran dieser fake account angelegt wurde
von mir und der war echt heftig aktiv
also ich würde wirklich an einem tag von
neun jungs oder was weiß ich wie alt die
wahl ist zwischen 16 und 20 oder so
wurde ich kontaktiert ob das wirklich
ich bin und auch nur aus dem grund weil
die mich von youtube kennen wo ich mir
gedacht habe tiger vielleicht kennt mich
von leuten die da angemeldet sind 1
prozent oder so höchsten von youtube und
wirklich neuen leute mitgeschrieben ich
stehe leute hast du denn eingeschrieben
alter so das ist das profil das gutes
ich hab schon hinbekommen dass er
gesperrt wird bzw
der wird von heftig vielen leuten
gemeldet weil ihr steht was weiß ich
wieder sich genannt hat hier steht auf
jeden fall dass der aus münchen kommt
ich komme aus bielefeld das wissen
vielleicht die ein oder anderen alter 17
okay das habe ich immer instabiler
beschreibung glaube ich überall stehen
die wn aller seit 19 siebter 2016 heute
ist der 22 genau das war wirklich
vorgestern und der war einfach heftig
aktiv 174 stimmt mich athletisch das
stimmt natürlich schon also ich bin 19
17 180 vielleicht wenn ich schon ab auch
ein bisschen größer und keine ahnung
sodann orientierung es ist anscheinend
ein homosexuelles forum schwul
coming-out komplett geoutet alles klar
komplett geoutet des vielfach ich auch
videos auf youtube in meiner freundin so
nicht drauf hat es stimmt dazu wach was
richtig und so weiter und und dann steht
hier ganz unten noch in sehr politischer
satz den traummann gibt es nicht und
jährige was schreibt wie sie einen
traumtyp sein soll versteckt sich vor
der realen welt la gibt es dinge die man
besonders gibt aber selbst das zeichnet
kein traum anja dann habe ich jetzt
wirklich zwei leute die halt wirklich
aktiv mit ihm geschrieben haben dazu
bekommen dass sie mir screenshot senden
von dem ganzen chat verlauf und da war
ich dann will ich zum teil schon so
recht einfach für mich wie es eben auch
schon gesagt habe so wirklich komplett
übertrieben ich meine wenn du neun leute
also ich weiß nicht wie viele du an
geschrieben hast aber man kann doch auch
mit diesem sheik dasein sag ich mal
du kannst ja heute schon dazu bringen
dass sie nicht wirklich toll finden und
dass sie sich unbedingt mit ihr treffen
soll und was darauf ein bild es gibt ja
sogar schon studien die belegen dass man
allein durch schreiben stand ein
bisschen verlieben kann oder so sei es
eingestellt keine ahnung aber ich finds
halt hast du keine hobbys man gehe nach
draußen geben ein ding pokémon golf
spielen oder wie das heißt aber mach
doch nicht so eine scheiße soll jetzt
will ich gar nicht lange lagern wir
kommen jetzt direkt mal zu den verläufen
der username von dem typen ist doodle
was weiß ich auf jeden fall wie bei mir
in der stadt thun erkennen mich und
wissen es auf fanbase ihr seid super sag
ich mal
ich würde niemals in meinem leben so
schreiben fanbase ihr seid super sage
ich mal da würde ich eher sagen wo ihr
seid richtig geil auf jeden fall kann
ich mir gut vorstellen das ist wirklich
ein typ ist er schon so 30 ist oder so
von der schreibweise her also jetzt bei
diesen sätzen gleich wird es noch ein
bisschen schlimmer und diese aussage
hier unten dass ich alles auf youtube in
blamabler bitte nicht auf meinen pages
posten meine folgen weiß bescheid nur
wir warten noch auf den richtigen moment
ist alles zu sagen also halt dass ich
dann offiziell homosexuell bin so das
ergibt keinen sinn meine freundin weiß
bescheid
ich kann noch gar keine freundin haben
auch diese sache so zu schreiben
du bist ein kleiner du bist einfach nur
1 so war zumal so kommen wir zum
nächsten screenshot auch aus dem
gleichen chat verlauf der einfach so von
arroganz nicht zu übertreffen ist auf
jeden fall
du bist ja nicht mal ich und schreibt
als wärst du der größte welser auf
dieser welt ich weinen weißt du
eigentlich wie viele nachrichten ein
youtube star bei den ganzen plattformen
bekommt wenn du und gerade dieses video
schauen sollte es vielleicht mal als
kleiner tipp von mir zu dir wenn du
wirklich mal einen partner finden
möchtest dann rate ich ist ihr
vielleicht nicht so arrogant zu
schreiben weil das kommt bei keinem gut
glaub mir darauf diese nachricht bei
meiner familie es heißt nicht dass die
ganze welt wissen muss wie so bezieht
ihr dieses komplett geoutet auch die
ganze welt die ja du hast doch auf
seinem account selber geschrieben
komplett geoutet bist du dumm oder was
es ist einfach nur ein zeichen von
richtiger dummheit geht ich vergraben
also kommen wir zum zweiten stellt
verlauf auch in dieser stelle vielen
dank an nicht du hast alles raus kopiert
und noch mal
ja ich irgendwie zusammengefasst auf
jeden fall cool danke und ja wir kommen
direkt zum ersten screenshot wo
drinsteht ja zum glück bekommt es keiner
mit und ich bitte dich ist auf meiner
welche posten helfe jetzt ja das bin ich
kann mich also doch ja das bin ich
kennen sie mich also doch schon der
zweite fan chat auch wieder eine sehr
arrogante aussage wie ich finde das
heißt nicht nur weil der mich kennt dass
er ein fan ist oder nicht so ich sage
dann mal gute nacht und wünsche dir
einen schönen schlaf sowie süße träume
ist danke dass du zu mir hält finde ich
echt super und ich schreibe dir nachher
das ist ich weiß nicht wann wie tief
willst du singen in deinem fucking leben
an
ich hoffe du wirst mal richtig
geschlagen und irgendwem
das sollte man keinem wünschen aber ich
hoffe du siehst dieses video geh mal
irgendwie dich beraten lassen irgendwo
oder so dass das wäre echt eine
besserung danke ja weil ich hab das
jetzt einfach mal so gut wie möglich
zusammengefasst noch mal eine kleine
meinung an nicht zum ende wenn du das
noch mal siehst du bist ja wenn euch das
video gefallen hat dann schreib doch
einfach mal eure meinung dazu in die
kommentar oder wenn ihr das genauso
sieht wie ich dass sowas einfach total
krank ist dann lasst einfach mal daumen
nach oben da was ich eigentlich denke
dass die meisten von euch auch so sehen
auf jeden fall instagram snapshot alles
eingeblendet ins 30 alexander v als alex
w aber nicht vergessen und mich zu
hassen wir sehen uns dann am nächsten
montag oder dienstag wieder abends
irgendwann verdrängt und schalteten ein
und ich hab euch alle ganz doll lieb und
ich wünsche euch süße träume und im
bereich